et pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
ménudier professeur honoraire à
l'université de la sorbonne nouvelle
spécialiste des francos les relations
franco-allemandes bonsoir on lit mais
lui dit merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on entendait donc ce
ministre albanais premier ministre
albanais qui al'air forcément déçu
est-ce que c'est clairement destiné à
ces pays l'albanie la macédoine
notamment les pays des balkans qui
souhaitent entrer dans l'union
européenne et à qui on veut clairement m
aujourd'hui les bâtons dans les roues
pas tellement des bâtons dans les roues
mais il faut se mettre d'accord sur les
processus
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que le
principe de l'élargissement est un
principe des fondateurs de l'union
européenne en effet lorsque robert
schuman a lancé son idée d'une
réconciliation d'une coopération
franco-allemande le 9 mai 1950 il avait
dit non seulement cela intéresse à
france et l'allemagne mais les autres
pays européens
j'ai ainsi qu'a été créée d'abord
l'europe des six et puis en 1973 on a
élargi la gamme avec la grande-bretagne
d'allemagne et cetera l'europe des neuf
et on en était donc à l'europe des 28
depuis quelques jours un état en moins
la grande bretagne
donc c'est le principe de la suppression
de l'élargissement tout à fait tout à
fait fondamental lors donc il fallait
continuer dans ce sens là c'est pour ça
que la prise de position de des manuels
macron l'automne dernier avait beaucoup
choqué en disant non une
une ouverture vers les autres pays des
balkans lors d'autant que deux autres
états était déjà entrée de l'ex
yougoslavie dans l'union européenne
la slovénie la croatie dont comprenait
en comprenait difficilement pourquoi on
lui en avait laissé entrer deux états
même s'il était un peu plus avancés sur
le plan économique et politique les
autres mais on pouvait pas laisser en
plan si vous voulez les autres petits
états surtout si on considère que il
représente un ensemble les populations
relativement réduits et six états
balkaniques dont il est question
actuellement représente en gros 18
millions d'habitants
quand on sait que la hollande les pays
bas représentent 17 millions d'habitants
on se rend compte que c'est pas un
énorme problème en fait pour l'union
européenne
on parle de poids finalement un
mécanisme bureaucratique peut-être les
politiques
oui certainement il ya un problème de
transparence ces négociations sont
extrêmement compliquées
elles durent très longtemps la plupart
des pôles et six pays
les six pays balkanique en question
actuellement
ce sont des négociations qui ont
commencé pratiquement au début des
années 2000 dont vous voyez une dizaine
d'années plus tard on a parfois très peu
très peu très peu avancé
ce sont des koné gociations entre les
états avec l'union européenne la
commission et ça dure ça dure beaucoup
de temps parce qu'il faut bien sûr que
ces pays puissent être en mesure mais de
s'intégrer dans l'union européenne
donc il faut qu'il se développe sur le
plan économique social
il faut également que ils remplissent un
certain nombre de critères sur le plan
démocratique ce soit des régimes qui
corresponde aux autres des états membres
de l'union européenne
donc tout cela fait que le processus est
très entraînant ariane nouveauté aussi
le mécanisme réversible c'est une
réponse aux breaks site
non mais c'est en fait je crois le pré
le président français le maquereau qui a
lancé cette idée
et dire que
en cours des négociations si jamais un
état adoptent des positions
anti-démocratiques ou qui choque si vous
voulez qu'ils ne voteront pas et qui
sont pas en parallèle avec celle des
autres états membres
on peut arrêter négociations et
l'interrompt peu plus ou moins longtemps
en attendant que le pays se remette ils
sont dans le droit chemin
sur le plan démocratique donc se
préciser il était proposé
si j'ai bien compris par les deux mâles
par un maquereau et l'union européenne
la commission européenne a repris cette
idée alors clairement une victoire
aujourd'hui diplomatique d' emmanuel
macron oui c'est une victoire c'est une
victoire diplomatique dans mesure où
finalement il ya eu un compromis qui a
été fait c'est à dire que la commission
il a été très critiqué en octobre
dernier lorsqu'il avait refusé de points
que les négociations soient poursuivis
cela a obligé la commission européenne à
faire des propositions on s'est un peu
rencontré au milieu faut pas oublier que
le président macro se trouvent en
situation relativement difficile sur le
plan européen
son idée centrale au départ c'était la
réforme de la zone de la zone euro ce
n'a pas eu lieu en grande partie à cause
de l'allemagne
mais maintenant il ya un deuxième projet
qui présente c'est l'un convention sur
l'avenir de l'europe
on ne sait pas ce que ça va devenir les
pourparlers devraient s'ouvrir dans les
semaines à venir
donc il reste cette troisième idée
maintenant de l'élargissement est
évident que peut pas rester sur une
position où ils bloquer la négociation
donc il espère que en lâchant un peu de
lest sur le principe de l'élargissement
et il y aura des soutiens concernant son
projet de future convention sur l'avenir
de l'europe
vous dites lâcher du lest mais est ce qu
il en a lâché beaucoup justement là je
crois que lâcher un peu rebelle points
je crois d'abord pour des raisons
financières ici bien sûr que les la
situation financière de l'union
européenne est difficile surtout après
le départ des britanniques qui était un
pays un contributeur net donc il faut
rétablir si vous voulez des finances de
l'union européenne et il est évident que
si on accepte les états et qui restent
encore les six états de dubal quand ça
va coûter relativement cher donc il ya
un problème financier qui se pose et je
suppose que s'il a fait les quelques
compromis sur le plan juridique c'est
parce qu'il a obtenu des assurances sur
le club sur le plan financier
est-ce que selon vous je m'adresse grand
spécialiste de l'europe que vous êtes
est ce qu'une refonte de la procédure
d'adhésion à l'union européenne était
vraiment nécessaire aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas que c'était absolument
nécessaire mais on se rend compte que ce
sont des procédures qui sont langues qui
sont très lourdes et ma foi si on peut
faire mieux si on peut faire si vous
voulez lui telle façon que les résultats
soient peut-être plus rapide parce que
l'une des difficultés de ces procédures
de d'élargissement c'est que c'est
toujours très longtemps et ça amène si
vous voulez des positions de dur j'ai
des fois au sein des au sein des pays
candidats
donc maintenant on pourrait y voir clair
beaucoup plus rapidement et je crois que
c'est bon pour l'union européenne
quand on voit le processus qui avait
débuté sur la turquie y est voilà les
développements ces dernières années est
ce que parfois il n'y a pas intérêt
système en sur les procédures soit
longue
oui bien sûr mais la turquie la turquie
candidat depuis les années 1980 je crois
les négociations ont été ouvertes
véritablement du temps du président
chirac et dumas chancelier schröder en
2005 dont vous voyez ça fait
pratiquement 15 ans et on n'a guère
avancé il n'y a pas de perspective de
deux percées de cette négociation
il est évident que les marins de traîner
des dossiers aussi aussi longtemps c'est
pourquoi la nouvelle procédure qui a été
proposé par paris et qui a été donc
soutenu par par bruxelles par l'union
européenne est certainement
une bonne chose si vous voulez pour
l'avenir de l'union européenne des
balkans à zagreb en mai prochain
qu'est ce qu'on doit on attendre est-ce
que tout va se jouer là bas
oui certainement je pense que d'abord on
aura une première indication au mois de
mars lors du prochain sommet européen
c'est de la réunion des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement on va examiner donc l'un
accord le compromis entre la france et
la commission européenne
je suppose que tel que se présentent les
choses actuellement il y aura il y aura
d'accord donc ça permettra ensuite à
cette réunion à laquelle vous faites
allusion de déboucher sur des décisions
tout à fait concrète et de d'ouvrir une
perspective de les négociations merci
beaucoup ont rêvé nude et je rappelle
que cette professeur honoraire à
l'université de la sorbonne nouvelle
spécialiste notamment des relations
franco-allemandes merci à vous merci